مرحبا، أنا ندى من شركة wanderwith،
وأود أن آخذكم اليوم في رحلة عن نصائح السفر. يلا!
[ شارة البداية ]
تذكرة الطيران هي الجزء الأكثر كلفة لدى التحضير للعطلة.
يبحث كل شخص عن رحلة الطيران الأرخص.
ولكن الأسعار عادة ما تكون في صعود او هبوط لعدة أسباب،
ولا يمكن لأحد توقع متى يتغير السعر ماعدا شركة الطيران نفسها.
هناك عدة طرق لتخفيف التكلفة:
الأولى هي: كن مرنًا في اختيار تواريخ وأوقات السفر.
عند البحث عن الرحلات الجوية، حدد خيار تواريخ سفر مرنة -/+ 3 أيام.
ستندهش من مدى رخص التذاكر خلال أيام الأسبوع أو اوقات معينة بناءً على وجهتك.
ويمكنك استخدم أداة البحث "للشهر بأكمله" بدلاً من تواريخ محددة للعثور على أفضل وأرخص يوم للسفر إلى وجهتك المختارة.
احجز رحلتك مسبقا لا تنتظر للحظة الأخيرة.
ينصح العديد من الخبراء بحجز رحلتك قبل 6 إلى 8 أسابيع من مغادرتك الى وجهتك خلال موسم الذروة
هناك مواقع تعلمك متى تكون أسعار التذاكر رخيصة لوجهتك
مثلwww.momondo.comو
www.googleflights.com
وتخبرك ايضا بالحجز فورا او الانتظار كما تقوم بإرسال تنبيهات لك
عند وجود احتمال بهبوط الأسعار او ارتفاعها.
لا تبحث فقط عن الرحلات الجوية المباشرة.
توفر العديد من شركات الطيران رحلات أرخص
إذا كنت مستعداً للتوقف في مكان أو إثنين
قبل الوصول إلى الوجهة النهائية.
قم أولاً بالبحث عن أسعار التذكرة المباشرة
ثم قم بمقارنتها بأسعار الرحلات غير المباشرة.
وينصح بالتأكد من وجود 3 ساعات على الأقل بين رحلات الطيران
خصوصا عندما تكون وجهة الترانزيت أحد المطارات المزدحمة والكبيرة.
قم بالتسجيل في برامج ولاء شركات الطيران
واكسب أميال للحصول على المكافآت والمزايا
مثل رحلات مجانية
وترقيات.
في أغلب برامج الولاء تحصل على نقطة ولاء مقابل كل ميل جوي تسافره،
أو حتى بلا أن تسافر،
فهناك شركات طيران متعاقدة مع بطاقات الائتمان
حيث تحصل على أميال جوية مقابل الإنفاق من البطاقة.
هناك ثلاث اتحادات لشركات الطيران في العالم
مثل ون ورلد، سكاي تيم و ستار اليانس
حيث اذا اكتسبت أحد الأميال الجوية من السفر على شركة طيران ضمن برنامج من نفس نظام الولاء
فبإمكانك استبدال النقاط والسفر على خطوط أخرى من نفس البرنامج.
إن شاء الله تكونوا قد استمتعوا معي في هذه الجولة،
واستفدتم من هذه النصائح.
[ شارة النهاية ]